congratulations to you tonight's unsung
hero what does this mean to you and you
really are a celebrity that does so much
and you never rah-rah about it you just
show up for people
I do my best and and um you know years
ago when my girlfriend Kristin Martinez
was diagnosed with stage 4 metastatic
breast cancer at the age of 32 all I
knew is that I wanted to try to save her
life or prolong her life and I just
don't to the breast health work and here
we are you know almost ten years after
she passed away still doing the work and
still trying to educate and still trying
to inspire people to be their own best
advocates and not let fear get in the
way of getting the education and
information that can save your life
and now that you're a mama does your
good works in the world mean a little
more or do you think differently about
the time you spend for other people you
know it's that's part of the balance
that we're all sort of struggling for
because there's so much work to do on so
many fronts but I just want to stare at
her little face but it does remind me
that life is precious and if there's
lives that I can save by using my
platform to educate and inspire I got to
do that and hopefully she'll understand
there's always the talk of like who does
baby take after mommy or daddy it's
she's an actress honey
she's an actress real she's very real
she picks up she sees the camera and
she's like where's my agent we haven't
negotiated this picture so she looks
like dad negotiating skills of mom and
congratulations on the new gig America's
Got Talent we're so excited I know we
start in a couple days so I'm really
excited I don't know what to expect I'm
just ready and waiting for all of the
the best talent Mariga has to offer last
thing we're doing a huge week on the
25th anniversary of friends and we've
gotten with the entire cast tell me
about your moment guest starring on that
show and what you remember I remember
that it was just the gig I got after my
show City of Angels was canceled
and I didn't realize it was a big deal
because I didn't watch friends and it
wasn't until later they were like oh you
know you were the first african-american
love interest on friends and I was like
but it's set in New York how and I
didn't realize I you know it was a
bigger deal until much later and I was
like cool glad the check cleared you
know congratulations on everything I'm
so happy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]